nous sommes avec le député de haute
garonne sébastien en ado bonjour à vous
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sommateurs vous vous êtes le corps a pas
encore à porter d'un rapport intitulé
refondation démocratique de l'union
européenne examiné par la commission des
affaires étrangères et puis publié en
on est donc à la veille du bric site
pour qui finalement ça va être le plus
difficile à partir de 23 heures demain
l'europe l'union européenne ou londres
alors d'abord c'est un processus
politique qui s'annonce pour demain mais
c'est vraiment dans les mois qui
viennent que les difficultés vont
s'ammonceler et j'ai bien peur que ce
soit pour d'une part les citoyens
britanniques d'autre part certaines
catégories de citoyens européens que ce
sera le plus compliqué
la responsabilité de la grande bretagne
dans tout ça je suis pas sûr que tout
soit bien évalué vis-à-vis des gens et
donc les populations
il ya un risque il ya un risque qu'il
faut faut être efficace politiquement
dans les négociations qui s'annoncent
qui s'annonce déjà extrêmement compliqué
et donc il va falloir avoir beaucoup de
vigilance et soutenir une démarche très
collective au niveau de l'union
européenne dans ces négociations
est-ce que vous pensez que du côté
britannique finalement il va y avoir une
certaine forme de nostalgie à partir de
vendredi ou pas écoutez moi ce que je
veux mettre en parallèle c'est ce qui
s'est passé hier au parlement européen
vous avez d'un côté nigel farrage avec
une certaine agressivité
beaucoup de rancoeur vis-à-vis l'union
européenne et puis tous les
parlementaires européens qui chante ce
n'est qu'un au revoir avec cette manière
de dire au revoir à un ami
donc moi je pense que là vraiment une
question c'est quel comportement va
adopter la grande bretagne mais les
signes avant coureurs sont pas
extrêmement positif alors j'espère que
boris johnson aura une autre manière de
penser la relation à l'europe parce que
cette relation le président de la
république l'a dit elle est inévitable
incontournable
la grande-bretagne quitte l'union
européenne mais enfin la grande bretagne
géographiquement reste au même endroit
et c'est un partenaire c'est un
partenaire au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies qui est essentiel pour la
france donc on a besoin de travailler
ensemble
j'ai quelques inquiétudes sur sur la
capacité des politiques britanniques
actuelle à bien gérer leur propre
transition
alors moi ce que je souhaite c'est que
la france et l'union européenne
fasse endosser la responsabilité de
leurs gestes politiques aux britanniques
c'est à dire que il est nullement
question que ce soit l'union européenne
qui se retrouvent en difficulté en subir
les conséquences de ce retrait il ya eu
donc une part de transition qui va se
profile à partir de demain jusqu'à la
fin de l'année
durant cette période il va falloir pour
londres c'est l'objectif ce sera de
renégocier en fait négociés de nouvelles
relations commerciales avec bruxelles
qu'elle pourrait être justement cette
nouvelle relation commerciale
écoute c'est difficile à dire parce que
il ya eu quand même pas mal de
revirements depuis le vote des
britanniques sur cette issue de break
site
donc on avance quand même dans des
sables mouvants et tout cela est assez
inquiétant d'un point de vue d'un point
de vue diplomatique et d'un point de vue
des accords commerciaux qui peuvent voir
le jour là la grande bretagne semble
immédiatement se tourner vers les états
unis
trump est bien content donald trump est
bien content de m'être on va dire un
coin dans l'organisation de l'union
européenne à travers le brésil va
s'appuyer sur ça pour continuer d'une
certaine manière sa guerre économique
donc comment comment va jouer la grande
bretagne dans ce jeu on le sait pas
encore je pense que c'est un jeu à hauts
risques davantage pour la grande
bretagne que pour l'union européenne
mais il faut que l'union européenne soit
suffisamment solidaire et et forte de
son histoire
il faut quand même pas oublier que
la grande bretagne est rentré dans
l'union européenne c'est au forceps et
dans la douleur le général de gaulle on
voulait pas il a fallu attendre que le
général de gaulle soit plus au pouvoir
en france finalement pour qu'en 1973 la
grande-bretagne rentrer dans l'union
européenne
et aujourd'hui elle en sort moi je
trouve qu elle en sort par la petite
porte et il va falloir effectivement
être très très vigilant sur les accords
commerciaux notamment c'est une évidence
mais aussi sur certaines catégories
je pense aux pêcheurs particulièrement
impacté par par les questions
territoriales et des zones de pêche
merci beaucoup sébastien nadeau pour
avoir réagi en direct sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes député de la
haute garonne merci à vous